also tonight our Police Department's
latest crime numbers show a dramatic
decrease in property crimes along the
resort Corridor thanks for joining us at
11 I'm Denise Valdez I'm David charns
Brian will explains why we're seeing
this drop what it means for you and your
neighborhood and for the busiest place
in the valley he's live on the strip
tonight Brian
yeah David and Denise when digging into
these crime numbers tonight you can see
that property crimes relating to
robberies and burglaries are down nearly
40 percent while car thefts are down
nearly 20 percent in overall arrests
here on the resort Corridor are up 44
for an economy that relies on its
tourists it's a good sign
the strip itself is a is the lifeline of
uh I believe our state uh to enhance
Safety and Security measures and to
invest in those measures Jonathan
Alvarez with Crime Stoppers of Nevada
says the drop in crime along the resort
Corridor is thanks to efforts from law
enforcement and private security like
his firm protective Force International
I think a lot of it has to do with law
enforcement's community outreach and how
they are so transparent within uh our
community Alvarez says that transparency
can help build trust within the
community leading locals to report more
crimes he also says security is like an
onion there's a lot of layers you have
video surveillance uniformed and visible
security personnel and covert or hidden
security measures that the public is not
aware of the workers themselves in the
casinos that place a huge role in force
multiplier where the casinos themselves
are investing in Safety and Security
Training bringing all these efforts
together when compared to last year at
this time robberies are down by 12.
burglaries down by 103 and vehicle
thefts down by 34. increase enforcement
measures and increased safety measures
ultimately provide and prove that you
can have a safer community
now Alvarez tells me the best way to
protect yourself is to be aware of your
surroundings which can be as simple as
just putting your phone down and looking
around live on the Strip Brian will 8
news now a reminder if you know
something about any criminal activity
you should always report it to Crime
Stoppers and they do offer rewards you
can call
702-385-55 and always remain anonymous